yeah well it's uh day one here in buenos
aires
uh loving it we are in the area known as
palermo
lovely restaurants
and
coffee shops
i got to be careful here because we're
on the hop-on hop-off bus it's supposed
to come by in four minutes or so i don't
want to miss it
uh
very friendly
uh you know
it's interesting i had to go to staples
because
i had
purchased this visa to brazil
through the internet and
forgot to bring the visas
so in this modern world i had to phone
the company that arranges the visa which
is located in india
and they then gave me the directions on
how to access this
so on my ipad
on my ipad
i downloaded the pdf file then i went to
the local staples
shop
just around the corner from where we're
staying
and then i connected their wi-fi
and they gave me their email address i
emailed them the pdf file and they
printed it and now we have our visas
pretty good and then i stopped by for
some media lunas which is how they say a
croissant here
and some fruit which we had with coffee
and our little uh airbnb apartment
and but people are just
nice friendly they line up for the bus
which is something i didn't expect here
uh it's just neat
uh they're not strong on picking up the
dog poop off of the sidewalk so you kind
of have to watch where you walk
but
other than that so far the
impression is extremely favorable and
we're about to head off on our bus tour
[Music]
you